[Music]
these marshmallows take over 24 hours to
make and are completely homemade they
turn into a beautiful rainbow melty
s'more today i'm trying the rainbow
s'more along with florida's most famous
cookies and a mochi hot chicken sandwich
to see which food will come out on top
today i'm here at east end market one of
the most popular food markets in central
florida every month they host the
evening exchange where vendors get
together and debut some of their best
creations so we created a signature
event once a month to bring out like the
best makers foodpreneurs and slam them
all into one night you know we really
champion small makers and we're not
about franchise and it's really about
giving someone an opportunity to take
what they love and show it off to the
community it's a really cool place to
kind of taste and see what orlando's all
about
gideon's cookies were voted the best
cookies in the entire state of florida
and they're known for being completely
covered in chocolate chips the line is
always out the door to try these and i'm
ready to find out what the hype is about
i never honestly meant to open up a
bakery it was something that a lot of my
family and friends really pushed me into
the cookies were actually a hobby of
mine that i worked on for about 15 years
before i decided that the chocolate chip
cookie was finalized i joked that the
secret ingredient in the cookies are my
tears our cookies are just shy of a half
pound each we make almost half pound
cookies but we do hand weigh shape
decorate by hand every single cookie to
make sure that every bite is the perfect
bite
we've been open for three years now i
think we've sold out just about every
single day part of the experience of
getting a cookie at gideon's is
sometimes waiting in line 80 minutes to
get a cookie
but the friends that you can make in
that line
can be a glorious thing
i think probably the the greatest
compliment that we've received as a
business was a woman that was 102 years
old and nothing ever came close to the
cookie that she had at gideon's fake
house
this cookie stands out amongst other
chocolate chip cookies because it's got
a lot of those chocolate chips it's
seriously like biting through a barrier
of chocolate to get to the cookie it's
really moist and dense and buttery and
lots of chocolate power in there but if
you're in orlando i think it's
definitely worth giving them a try all
the foods i'm trying today are homemade
creations from orlando locals and our
next food is made with less than 10
ingredients that are all made from
scratch and locally sourced
sugar rush marshmallows was started by
wife and wife team julie and jean
summers back in 2016. making these
marshmallows is not easy each batch has
six layers of color from red to purple
and takes about six hours to make
after the layering process the
marshmallows need to sit for 24 to 48
hours before they can be cut powdered
and packaged when we make our sugar
syrup we make our vanilla extract we
make any of our extracts and flavorings
we make our source locally to try to
highlight local flavors and but then on
top of that to make it a little bit
extra special we make our own graham
crackers so it's a lot of extra work but
we think that it's definitely worth it
to have that
extra special experience i think sets
our marshmallows apart
there's such a soft spot in my heart for
a beautiful rainbow dessert and this
s'more is truly one of a kind
oh my god
i love this rainbow s'more because they
take something so classic and simple
and they turn it into something so fun
and decadent
the marshmallow is the most delicious
marshmallow i've ever had the graham
crackers are buttery homemade throw it
all together i'm over the moon for this
over the rainbow after two delicious
sweet treats i'm trying a limited
edition sweet and spicy combo that has
taken the internet by storm it's a hot
fried chicken sandwich on a mochi donut
bun i mean just even when we announced
it just as a teaser announcement i mean
we got so many hits on social media just
people like when is it coming out what
is this you know i want to see it and as
soon as we showed first pictures of it i
mean people started going insane over it
about 10 45 there's a line of about 25
people waiting to get this sandwich
we knew obviously it's an instagramable
thing it's something they both look
really nice really pretty together but
the actual flavors really went well
together because the the doji is a nice
like way with the mochi flower the rice
flour so it's really crispy on the
outside but kind of chewy on the texture
on the inside and our hot chicken how we
do it and how we make it it's really
nice and crispy on the outside as well
and then our
chicken's really juicy and nice so it's
like all the textures went together like
a layer of similar texture so it went
together really nicely so it's been very
limited and
and truth be told each time it's
completely sold out i mean we've sold
out down to the last tinder and
obviously there's limitations in terms
of being on a trailer in terms of how
much but i mean i'm talking several
cases of chickens gone there's nothing i
love more than a culinary contrast
meaning two flavors that are completely
different but bring a beautiful marriage
together
[Music]
oh
oh it's hot now
we went from sweet
to hot
whoa
oh no
it's hot oh my god i am on fire right
now the fact that this is the mild
sandwich if i had the hot sandwich i
would have to truly go to the hospital i
mean
i think they're culinary geniuses
i tried so many amazing foods today and
this might be the hardest decision i've
had to make between gideon's famous
cookies sugar rush's amazing marshmallow
rainbow s'more and the douchey chicken
fire sandwich i had some of the most
interesting foods here than i've ever
had but
my favorite is the rainbow s'more i
have had many a s'more in my lifetime
and i have never had a marshmallow so
silky so creamy and so
beautiful and since i used to have my
own rainbow cake ball company rainbow
desserts have a place in my heart
i'm already having such a great time but
the fun is just getting started i'm
gonna go enjoy the evening exchange but
don't forget to stay hungry
[Music]